let's talk about investing so here one
thing I hear quite commonly from people
in their 20s is to say why should I save
money it's much harder for me to save a
little bit of money right now why
shouldn't I just start saving money and
investing in my 30s and to be frank I
used to think like that in my early 20s
as well so thankfully over time my
mindset on this changed a little bit the
first is the value of habits the value
of getting used to that so if you've
never really got any experience any
habits in saving your money if you just
always spending it all it will be
extremely difficult for you to suddenly
in your 30s to start saving a
substantial amount of your income every
single month